[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
journal sur tv et 78 nous sommes le
lundi 30 octobre tout de suite les
titres de cette édition
elle gère 50 forêt domaniale en ile de
france dont celle de rambouillet et de
port royal à magny-les-hameaux l'office
national des forêts met en place une
nouvelle stratégie meilleure maîtrise de
la récolte du bois pour éviter les
changements trop brusque de paysages
nous en parlons avec michel béal
directeur de l'agencé territoriale ile
de france ouest daloa nef fil rouge de
cette semaine dans le 7-8 journal le
dossier de la rédaction sur l'après vie
dans les yvelines premier focus ce soit
sur l'assurance vie et l'assurance décès
qui permet d'aider financièrement ses
proches en cas de disparition
et puis il n'a rien d'un héros normal
raconte l'histoire d'un homme lâche qui
va devoir reprendre sa vie en main ce
court métrage sera montré à la
bibliothèque nationale de france dans le
cadre du festival paris court devant son
réalisateur originaire de la verrière
tony chasselas est notre invité est mais
avant de développer ces titres une
opération anti publicité ce week end à
versailles menée par l association el
résistance à l'agression publicitaire de
saint quentin en yvelines dans la nuit
de vendredi à samedi dernier les
militants ont procédé à l'extinction de
plusieurs enseignes lumineuses sur les
grands axes commerciaux de la ville et
les devantures d'une cinquantaine de
boutiques ont été ainsi éteintes actions
pour sensibiliser aux coûts énergétiques
écologiques ainsi qu'à la pollution et
visuelle de ces allumage il veille à
l'entretien le développement et le
renouvellement des espaces boisés
l'office national des forêts jarre en
ile de france près de 73 mille hectares
de forêt domaniale comme celle de
maurepas ou encore de bois d'arcy
bonsoir michel béal soit vous êtes le
directeur de l'agencé territoriale ile
de france ouest de l'eau et neff alors
lodève qui a mis en place une nouvelle
stratégie qui concerne les forêts
domaniales dans la région on va en
parler dans un instant parlons déjà de
votre agence savoir ce qu'elle
représente
elle couvre toute la partie ouest de
l'île de france et ça le val d'oise les
yvelines et aussi une partie de
l'essonne et les hauts-de-seine effectif
voilà en totalité le département des
yvelines et du val d'oise et les quatre
cinquièmes de l'essonne et dans l'eau
élèves dans les yvelines ça représente
combien de forêt ça représente quoi tout
dans l' agence nous gérons 42 mille
hectares de bois dont plus des trois
quarts sont des forêts domaniales
anciennes forêts royales qui sont tombés
dans le domaine de l'it as et que nous
gérons depuis maintenant deux très
longues décennies
et dans cette gestion bien sûr les
forêts domaniales aussi sont un lieu
d'exploitation on y produit et récolte
du bois de 134 mille mètres cubes ont
été ainsi à prélever en 2016 sur toute
l'île de france
ça sert à quoi au juste cette gestion
sylvicole des forêts la france a besoin
de bois l'île de france avec plus de 13
millions d'habitants aussi donc l'autre
souhait luan fc de pouvoir gérer les
forêts aussi pour cette fonction de
production faire en sorte aussi le bois
qui est produit par les forêts
naturellement puisse être transformée
utilisé par les franciliens cette
fonction-là complète également s'est
complété par deux autres fonctions qui
sont la fonction d'accueil du public et
la fonction de protection protection des
milieux et de la biodiversité
oui on y pense c'est d'ailleurs un peu
moins le fait de prélever du bois va
aider aussi à renouveler la les forêts
renouveler les espèces qui est plus de
diversité dans les espèces qu'on trouve
en forêt tout à fait c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui le souci des forestiers
c'est de faire en sorte qu' on est des
forêts qui puisse se régénérer se
renouveler jusqu'à maintenant on gérait
plus tôt les forêts sous forme de futaie
dite régulière c'est le principe c'est
comme un partout en france où on a sur
une même parcelle d âge des forêts des
arbres à peu près du même âge pardon
d'accord deux fois ce qui fait que
lorsque les arbres vieillissent arrive
vers la fin de leur vie nous les coupons
ce qui peut procurer de grands vides ce
qu'on appelle parfois les coupes rases
the
dans le paysage et ce qui est toujours
assez choquant aujourd'hui choquant mais
pour les visiteurs qui viennent
régulièrement en forêt s'y promener
faire du sport aussi celui qui habite là
où même les automobilistes qui
traversent et forêts aujourd'hui par nos
nouvelles orientations de gestion nous
souhaitons changer de mode de traitement
est passé à ce qu'on appelle la futaie
irrégulière le principe c'est d'avoir
des arbres au sein d'une même parcelle
avec des âges différents des vieux côtés
de jeunes ou de moyens de façon à ce que
lorsqu on prélèvera les arbres les plus
vieux bien sûr l'impact paysager sera
beaucoup plus faible et le public sera
moins choqué sur l'aspect de changement
de cet espace paysagé donc cette
modification et de la manière de couper
les arbres où on va le prélever c'est au
coeur oui de cette nouvelle stratégie
la volonté qui n'ait pu voler 10 des
espaces vides qu'on prélève des arbres
oui par petites parcelles finalement n'y
ait pas eu un gros changement de
l'aspect de la forêt exactement c'est
l'aspect changement c'est à dire que le
système régulier faisait que sur deux
trois quatre hectares à la fin de la vie
d'un peuplement on faisait une coupe qui
marque évidemment le paysage
demain ça sera plus des prélèvements qui
seront disséminées et lorsqu'on en la
barre arnor ça va créer une petite roue
et de quelques centaines de mètres
carrés mais pas plus
alors pourquoi ça devenait oui et
justement une nécessité de mettre en
place cette nouvelle gestion de la coupe
des arbres les lois n'est fait a été
créé il ya plus de 50 ans pour gérer des
forêts mais gérer des forêts pour
répondre aux besoins de la société je
pense qu'aujourd'hui la surtout en ile
de france le public francilien est plus
attaché à la forêt à ce paysage et pas
simplement à ce cadre de vie et donc
nous devons prendre en compte aussi
cette évolution des besoins cette
évolution de la société est adaptée de
notre notre mode de gestion de ces
forêts la dernière chose la fin prévue
de ces coupes rases c'est dans un délai
de sept ans c'est ça oui tous toutes les
forêts sont dotés d'un document de
gestion que l'eau nf établi qui a
approuvé par le ministère de
l'agriculture
nous allons pour appliquer ce nouveau
traitement
visez réécrire tous les documents de
gestion c'est un énorme travail que nous
allons faire qui va s'étaler sur sept
ans et en nous allons commencer par les
forêts les plus urbaines dont que
versailles bois d'arcy mais également
meudon fausses reposes qui songe aussi à
cheval sur le département des yvelines
merci michel béal d'avoir été avec nous
je rappelle vous êtes le directeur de
l'agencé territoriale ile de france
ouest à l'office national des forêts et
pour plus d'infos sur le nf vous pouvez
vous rendre sur le site internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran
comme à chaque fin de mois sur tv 78
c'est le dossier de la rédaction cette
semaine nous vous proposons une série de
reportages sur l'après vie dans les
yvelines premier zoom ce soir sur
l'assurance décès et l'assurance vie ce
sont deux produits financiers qui aide
les familles après une disparition
explications avec nicolas d'android
protéger ses proches financièrement
après sa disparition c'est possible
notamment avec l'assurance décès prenons
l'exemple d'un assuré qui souscrit un
contrat d'une garantie de 100 mille
euros pour dix ans ils paient une prime
mensuelle et en contrepartie l'assureur
est en charge de la gestion du dossier
en cas de décès avant la clôture du
contrat les cent mille euros sont versés
aux héritiers disons que pour une
personne qui a 40 ans qui veut se
garantir pour cent mille euros on
aronson dans des primes qui sont
relativement modestes on est à 30 ou 35
euros par mois
après si on veut un million d'euros et
si on a 50 ans on peut tout de suite
monté à des 100 ou 150 euros par mois
les inconvénients c'est que c'est à
fonds perdus donc il faut vraiment que
le décès se fasse durant la durée du
contrat
l' avantage c'est que ça permet de
donner aux héritiers une somme pour
continuer à vivre et ne pas réduire leur
train de vie
autre produit financier transmis en cas
de décès l'assurance vie le principe
épargner un capital avec deux
possibilités pour l'assurer première
solution un investissement dans un fonds
sécurisés principalement composée de
dette française la rentabilité dépend
alors de l'évolution des taux d'intérêts
deuxième possibilité il peut choisir des
fonds profilés avec un mélange de titres
financiers de type actions ou
obligations avec un niveau de bénéfice
un certain en fonction du marché ce qui
est un petit peu dommage
aujourd'hui les taux des fonds en euros
ont beaucoup baissé puisque on donne à
peu près 2 % de rendement et qu'on
essaye donc donc un petit peu relancé ce
rendement de mélanger les fonds en euros
avec des fonds en unités de compte et
des fonds profilés hervé rocheteau
dirige le service succession d'une
banque basée à montigny le bretonneux
il intervient après le décès des
personnes assurées différentes
vérifications l'acte de décès les
documents notariaux l'identité des
héritiers et parfois des certificats
médicaux son rôle accompagner les
proches du défunt
alors elle est décédée le 25 août les
sommes en jeu sont supérieurs à 150
mille euros en ce qui concerne l'
ensemble de l' épargne et pour les
presser un peu moins de 50000 euros
le prêt était assurée justement par le
biais des assurances décès ce qui
permettra je dois de les libérer de ce
prêt et ils vont pouvoir conserver toute
l'épargné
c'était l'intérêt de l'assurance décès
dans ce cas là il y a de l'assurance vie
avec plusieurs contrats des contrats
avec des clauses standard c'est à dire
personne de nommer et des contrats sur
lesquels au contraire il y à des enfants
ou des petits enfants qui sont nommés
qui vont pouvoir être réglé très
rapidement
généralement sous un mois donc on fait
vraiment haut au plus vite
lors des neuf premiers mois de 2010 est
les sociétés d'assurances ont collecté
80 17,3 milliards d'euros de cotisations
mensuelles pour l'assurance vie
ce type de produit reste le placement
préféré des français 43% d'entre eux
choisissent cette épargne selon un
sondage au dos que ça linxea devant le
livret a ou le pel ce sont toujours les
vacances et alors que certains en
profitent pour se reposer d'autres sont
en pleine formation au centre alfred de
vigny de voisins-le-bretonneux une
quinzaine de jeunes à passer le bafa
pour devenir animateur en centre de
loisirs
aujourd'hui c'était la dernière journée
de ce stage démarré le 23 octobre sur
place camille lambert
time's up qui est qui houba l'américaine
il vaut mieux avoir plus d'un jeu dans
son sac pour occuper les enfants
si ces séances ressemble un peu une
récréation ces adolescents sont bien en
plein apprentissage
c'est le premier stage du cycle de
formation bafa et il consiste en la
découverte des fonctions de l'animateur
qui sont donc abordé à travers des temps
de réflexion et des temps d'animation
sur l'île où on privilégie plutôt des
temps de réflexion qui leur permettent
de découvrir quels sont les différents
besoins des enfants selon les tranches
d'âge
comment s'organise et comment on gère la
vie quotidienne bien expliquer les
règles encadrent et être attentif aux
difficultés autant d'éléments à prendre
en compte pour devenir animateur une
quinzaine de jeunes se prête à
l'exercice avec plus ou moins
d'expérience j'ai fait beaucoup de colo
et d'accueil de loisirs quand j'étais
plus petit et j'aimais bien déjà
j'aimais bien les animateurs j'ai trouvé
ça marrant et je sais pas ça m'a
toujours attiré 2 d'animer des enfants
de jouer avec eux qu'est-ce qui est
difficile de savoir expliquer par
exemple des animations trouvé le temps
de l'es2 les faire et à notre âge c'est
un peu compliqué et ce qui est facile
c'est qu'on soit quand appartement on a
les petits pas des petites soeurs on
s'est un peu comment s'en occuper
j'ai plutôt voulu participer parce que
j'ai entraîne au foot et du coup sa mort
sam apprenez à à développer mes
connaissances sur les enfants quoi seule
condition pour passer son bafa être âgé
au minimum de 17 ans une première étape
quasiment validé pour ses candidats
les futurs animateurs auront encore deux
stages à passer avant d'obtenir leur
brevet son court-métrage parle d'un
homme normal qui va devoir reprendre sa
vie en main bonsoir tony chasselas vous
êtes originaire de laterrière et vous
êtes donc le réalisateur de normal ce
court métrage sera projeté est les 20 et
21 novembre prochain au festival paris
court devant je vous propose tout de
suite de regarder la bande annonce
[Musique]
vive dans la région
bon
[Musique]
qui va se prendre un raccourci j'aille
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la bande annonce du court métrage normal
on avec nous sur ce plateau son
réalisateur tony h à cela or normal
raconte l'histoire de mike un homme
normal comme le nom du court métrage
l'indiquent qui est il ce mic c'est un
personnage un peu inspirée d'une
connaissance à moi et des expériences
que ce ps cette personne a pu vivre
donc du coup c'est de la fiction mais il
ya toujours une part de vérité une
petite part d'inspiration de la vraie
vie dans ce personnage
j'aime beaucoup les super héros ça c'est
aussi quelque chose fort dans son
personnage
ça s'est un peu moins par contre
d'accord c'est un peu mon côté un peu
geek entre guillemets qui a dépeint sur
le personnage et c'est un caractère qui
est assez importante mais coup puisque
ça lui permet de s'identifier à ces
héros et de prendre plus ou moins sa vie
en main quand décider de le faire ou
c'est ça on n'en dit pas plus mais un
événement qui va arriver dans la ville
maille qui va l'obliger à reprendre sa
vie en main c'est ça tout à fait alors
ici ou pas à voir donc il s'agit de
votre premier court métrage qu'est ce
qui a motivé le choix de ce scénario de
parler de mike
ben c'est un scénario que j'avais depuis
un petit moment déjà donc ça faisait je
ne sais pas trois quatre ans que j'avais
ce scénario
est créé dans un côté dans mon téléphone
que je retouche et de temps en temps
et un jour j'ai trouvé une espèce de
cours sur paris qui nous était à faire
des courts métrages
donc j'ai proposé mon idée donc mon
idéal à plus donc j'ai été retenu pour
c'est un espèce d'ateliers et du coup
j'ai fait d'ateliers pendant un an et la
finalité de l'atelier c'était justement
de réaliser son court métrage et l envie
de réaliser ça vient d'où commencez
réalise depuis que je suis tout petit en
fait je prenais les caméras je faisais
des films avec mes amis donc j'ai encore
les bandes c'est quelque chose que j'ai
toujours fait mais je me suis jamais
penchée professionnellement en fait sur
la chose j'ai toujours préféré à faire
de la musique en fait j'ai fait pendant
dix ans j'ai fait de la musique
donc c'est ce que c'était ma priorité en
fête et au final je me suis rendu compte
que le cinéma c'était vraiment quelque
chose que j'avais envie de faire
finalement donc je me suis jeté à l'eau
commence alors ce court métrage normal
été réalisée en juin 2010 2016 c'est ça
si je veux me tourner en tournée en juin
2016 est donc réalisée dans la foulée et
les cinq continents auront sûrement
reconnu en bande annonce il ya une
partie du court métrage qui se déroule
dans le quartier 17 mars est en cours
exactement est tout à fait là où on a
été diffusée d'ailleurs il ya deux
semaines dans le cadre du festival ça
tourne en ile de france
d'ailleurs oui hasard ou pas oui disent
ce court métrage a été diffusée c'était
le 15 octobre dernier au ciné c'est
d'elancourt c'était aussi donc au coeur
de ce quartier 17 mar le festival voilà
le festival paris court devant vous êtes
classé troisième c'est de ce festival
lors de cette projection exactement pour
ainsi une première participation au
festival c'est déjà encourageant et de
finir déjà 3e tout à fait où et quand on
regarde les films qui était en
compétition avec moi la plupart de la
plupart avaient des productions donc moi
c'est vrai que c'est une autoproduction
donc c'était financé par la famille et
les amis en grande partie en majorité
donc
c'était déjà bien d'être sélectionné là
aujourd'hui le film il a quatre
sélections il a été projeté hier en inde
donc je suis vraiment content du
parcours du film pour un premier film
mondiale
ouais tout à fait donc je suis vraiment
ravi du parcours du film on voit lady la
autofinancement et quand on débute dans
la carrière de jeunes réalisateurs
quelles sont les solutions justement
pour financer son court métrage au début
ça démarre comme ça c'est de l'auto
financement on peut pas faire appel à
des financements des aides peut être
n'est il pas mais peu de l'exécuter on
peut contacter le cnc etc
mais c'est très difficile parce que ils
doivent recevoir un grain très grand
nombre de scénarios et on sélectionne
peut être 10 ou 5 est financé par an
donc c'est vraiment l'auto production de
la solution la plus facile entre
guillemets parce qu'il faut toujours
avoir les fonds faut avoir un bon
entourage et points d'andy d'e.on et sur
quel budget pour pour un court métrage
est normal pour normal on à 2000 euros
d'accord mais j'ai vraiment c'est à dire
que le film a été tourné en trois jours
il aurait dû être tourné en plus de
temps par exemple équipe réduite équipe
professionnelle mais qui est présumé de
caméras professionnelles mais avec des
tarifs préférentiels
c'est vraiment on a bataillé avant
d'arriver quand même alors il a été
retenu ce qu'on mettra dans la sélection
premium du festival paraît court devant
il sera donc diffusée hors compétition à
la bibliothèque nationale de france ça
sera les 20 et 21 novembre prochain on
imagine un grand tremplin c'est un grand
tremplin pour vous ou tout à fait ou est
ce qui est bien c'est qu'après cette
diffusion là les festivaliers la presse
ou les professionnels qui seront
présents ils ont les contacts et les
coordonnées des personnes qui ont
réalisé des films donc si jamais ils
envisagent une collaboration ou même des
interviews genre de choses on peut être
contacté directement d'accès c'est
vraiment c'est vraiment une chose je
pense que le parcours devant c'est un
des plus gros festivals en plus
ile-de-france donc éducation
internationale en plus c'est donc
vraiment c'est en moins d'un beau
parcours pour normes très rapidement il
nous reste peu de temps un mot sur vos
prochains projets là vous êtes dans la
réalisation d'un deuxième court métrage
qui éveille tournée d'ailleurs le
week-end prochain exactement dans
quelques jours entre eux ayant court
encore et être ap
c'est l'histoire d'une personne aux fins
d'une femme qui vient vraisemblablement
de commettre un meurtre
d'accord elle a j'en dis pas plus pour
laisser la surprise et d'ailleurs vous
pouvez suivre l'actualité du court
métrage normale et aussi l'actualité
tony chasselas sur le lien internet qui
s'affiche en bas de l'écran merci
anthony chasselas juste d'avoir été avec
nous alors appel vous êtes le
réalisateur de normal qui est donc
montrer qui sera montré dans le cadre du
festival paris court devant à la bnf
il fait partie de la sélection premium
de ce festival cinéma toujours avec une
saga qui a marqué plusieurs générations
quelques jours avant halloween les fans
d'harry potter avait rendez-vous à
versailles
trois acteurs des films sur le plus
célèbre des sorciers étaient présents à
l'hôtel de beauté pour signer des
autographes et échanger avec leurs
admirateurs nicolas landry et nicolas
kirilow its reconnaissez-vous ce jeune
homme blond avec des lunettes noires
sûrement pas si vous n'êtes pas un fan
de la saga harry potter yoga mitchell de
son vrai nom alias colleen krivets est
un jeune apprenti sorcier fans d'harry
potter et qui ne cesse de le prendre en
photo
un grand écuyer ce jour-là à versailles
les rôles sont inversés
la magie a opéré les fans moldus ont pu
rencontrer trois acteurs de la série
une occasion unique voire magique
d'échanger avec eux souvenirs et photos
on est vraiment tout seul avec le
traducteur et l'acteur on a deux petites
minutes pour vraiment on peut lui poser
une petite question ou deux et on estime
notre autographes donc c'est quand même
un moment de partage et c'est vraiment
bien la voir en vrai c'est encore
différent que la voir à l'écran puis
discuté un petit peu avec eux voir
comment ils sont plus dans la vraie vie
entre guillemets et oui enfin là les
voir et avoir un petit souvenir de quoi
organisée par la boutique spécialisée
versaillaise l'armoire geek ce week-end
rencontre a attiré plus de 2000
personnes pour le plaisir également des
acteurs j'adore participer à ce genre de
rencontre voir les fans de voir à quel
point ils sont passionnés
j'ai vraiment de la chance d'être
volaille pouvoir faire c'est la première
fois que je viens à versailles donc
c'est vraiment sympa c'est marrant de
rencontrer les fans je ne l'avais jamais
fait avant je n'avais pas encore eu
l'opportunité de le faire
une nouvelle rencontre est déjà prévue
l'an prochain entre fans et acteur à
versailles selon nos informations deux
journalistes moldus celle ci devrait
avoir lieu en février
harry potter c'est que si gratte et à la
veille d'halloween elles sont
indispensables pour une fête réussie
qu'elle fasse peur ou sourire les
citrouilles décor chaque année nos
maisons aux fermes de gally à
saint-cyr-l'ecole des ateliers sont
proposés aux enfants de 3 à 12 ans pour
creuser ça jack o lantern au riz rond et
mélanie poker se sont prêtés au jeu
des dizaines des centaines de
citrouilles avant de creuser première
étape il faut bien choisir sa jack
o'lantern la meilleure espèce qui la
trouvaient trop vite parce qu'elle est
lourde
direction l'atelier il faut maintenant
sculpter un premier dessin effet au
feutre
histoire de ne pas se tromper le
creusage donc ces faits par les enfants
une fois qu'on a ouvert la citrouille
des enfants up à creuse et enlève tous
les filaments qu'à l'intérieur auquel
soit tout propre nous on allait plutôt
donc comme c'est dangereux on a des
gants et on la découpe en faisant avec
eux en fonction de ce qu'ils veulent je
la grogne un peu celui là une fois la
citrouille terminer certains ont déjà
programmé leur soirée d'halloween
halloween ça fait taire et toi tu va
l'utiliser pour halloween
oui on va faire une activité la nuit
d'halloween tola four il y aura des
scènes des animateurs qui vous fait à
l'activité qui vont nous faire peur et
il y aura des surprises
vous n'avez pas encore votre citrouille
pas d'inquiétude les fermes de gally
propose des ateliers jusqu'au mardi 31
octobre alors rigolotes ou effrayantes
[Rires]
du sport verdict livré hier le 16e
tournoi d'échecs de la dame noire s'est
clôturé ce dimanche à la maison de la
réussite de montigny le bretonneux 30
joueurs se défiait depuis la semaine
dernière débutants comme expérimentés
âgés de 15 à 70 ans
trois trophées étaient a glané lors des
finales hier et les vainqueurs thomas
o'sullivan louis brémond et jean-marie
couratin le bilan de ce tournoi avec le
président de la dame noire au micro de
nicolas dans sas et gérait bien passé il
n'y a pas eu de demande de problème donc
il y avait une partie par jour donc tous
les jours à 14h30
on y ait quelques particules matin parce
qu'il y avait quelques joueurs des
empêchements mais globalement ça s'est
bien passé
prochain événement de la danois un
tournoi de noël du 27 au 30 décembre à
l'école éric satie de montigny le
bretonneux
on referme sur un journal par une idée
de sortie sorties culturelles en ces
vacances d'automne c'est une petite
demeure sur les hauteurs de saint rémy
les chevreuse à la maison martap années
andré voguant ce qui est ouverte au
public sur place un univers unique et
culturel une façon de redécouvrir
l'architecturé la sculpture du 20e
siècle
mathilde et demi voici la maison pensée
et réalisée à demain en 1952 à
saint-rémy-lès-chevreuse pas rendre
évoquant ce qui est marta pan ce célèbre
architecte et sept artistes
entretiennent l'unique maison de leur
vie qui va devenir historique la maison
elle est restée dans son état d'origine
donc on découvre ici une maison qui est
très représentative de l'esthétique des
années 50 avec des volumes très ouvert
une maison qui est très très lumineuse
une maison qui mêle espace de travail
espace de vie domestique sans aucune
séparation donc avec une porosité totale
entre les entre les deux une maison qui
a déjà tous les éléments du confort
moderne et dans le jardin vous trouvez
18 sculptures donc monumentale de marta
pan qu'elle les a installés à partir de
la fin des années 90 jusqu'à sa marque
donc un jusqu'en 2008
créateur phare de la sculpture et de l'
architecture le couple constitue une
fondation qui porte leur nom et qui au
fil des années entretient la maison nous
avons aussi un millier de dessins nous
avons l'ensemble de ces de ses écrits
sur lesquels
nous travaillons donc il ya un travail
d'inventaire et un travail classique de
conservation peas qui se fait le sens
muséographique du terme
et puis il ya tout un travail qui est
fait sur la connaissance la notoriété de
ces lots ces deux artistes jardin
typique espaces ouverts et couleurs
sombres la maison dévoile des années
d'architecturé de création plus grande
les unes que les autres
nous accueillons ici dans des publics
professionnels d'architecte ou
d'amateurs de dames plastique
nous accueillons des étudiants des
écoles architecture mais nous sommes
naturellement et surtout l'occasion des
journées du patrimoine a disposé
disponible pour recevoir un très très
large public en général nous accueillons
pendant ces 48 heures environ 1000
visiteurs certains venus de très loin
certains venus en voisins ouverte pour
un petit nombre de public
la maison vous accueillera toute la nuit
pour vous faire découvrir un espace
intime et bien pensé c'est la fin de ce
set 8 journal reportage replay sur notre
site internet et notre application
mobile tv 78 bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]